Moana is Disney's latest animated film
and this comes from the same creative
team behind Aladdin The Little Mermaid
Hercules The Princess and the Frog the
Great Mouse Detective and Treasure
Planet and this is one of the movies
that I got to see at AFI Fest with the
cast and crew there and that was a lot
of fun and this one's the story of a
young girl named Juana
who's daughter of the chief of her tribe
so she is soon to be princess and she
lives on an unspecified Polynesian
island with her friends and family and
everyone there believes that they have
to stay where they are if they venture
out forth beyond this island certain
death is certainly going to be involved
there's a legend of a demigod named Maui
who did battle with this ancient evil
and because of him they're stuck on an
island that is beginning to die so
despite her father's wishes she sets out
on an adventure on the ocean to find
Maui to hopefully set all of these
things straight just like with all of
Disney's animated films the animation is
stellar with each passing year Disney is
getting better and better at animating
photorealistic backgrounds especially
the ocean it felt like I could reach
into the screen and touch these things
that's how good it is the music in Moana
is also some of the best Disney's
produced recently there's one song in
this movie that's destined to be the
next let it go let's hope the radio
doesn't ruin it for all of us it's all
the things you'd want in a musical scene
like this they don't overstay their
welcome there isn't too much music it
doesn't become annoying the lyrics are
meaningful for the characters and their
catchy and fun to listen to once we
finally do meet the character of Maui
voiced by join Johnson he wants nothing
to do with this girl he just wants to
get back to his demigod like powers that
he has lost his body is covered in
tattoos and one of my favorite parts of
his character is that his tattoos
can move and tell stories on their own
he talks to them they can look back at
him and react to the decisions he's
making his tats were sort of like us as
the audience we want him to do certain
things we want him to help this girl and
one of my favorite parts of this movie
was watching Moana and Maui learned to
work together because she has to learn
how to sail and she has no idea how to
do that she's adventurous and very
courageous but she can't sail a boat and
Maui has to teach her this also gives us
a lot of really cool action sequences on
the
Oshin with some very original pirate
characters and a very badass ancient
evil that rises up out of the ocean it's
really exciting the action sequences in
this movie are very thrilling this is a
really fun Disney movie with all of the
things you'd want in a Disney film great
animation good voice work good songs a
good moral a good message all of those
things that you need in a Disney
animation like this but at the same time
I wouldn't say it's as good as another
film that came out this year by Disney
called Zootopia because Moana doesn't
really have as much on its mind its
story is just really exciting and fun
and there's nothing wrong with that but
Zootopia had very mature themes that
that film explored and it made me think
and it made me want to see it again and
again and again Moana I could see myself
watching every here and there because
it's as I said an extremely entertaining
movie with catchy music and great voice
acting and it looks amazing but there
just isn't that much under the surface
it also follows most of the traditional
tropes and cliches that we have come to
expect in a Disney film she has a little
tiny animal sidekick named hey hey this
really really stupid chiken voiced by
alan tudyk and this chicken got a lot of
laughs from the audience he was a really
fun character and it follows a familiar
path that we've seen in a lot of other
Disney films where we have two
characters that don't quite like each
other but they got to learn to work
together and we have our coming-of-age
hero character in Moana and we get to
watch her blossom into something
beautiful and we've seen that in movies
many times and Disney films but what's
special here is that we've never seen
this culture represented in a mainstream
Disney movie and that's awesome I'm
gonna give Moana and a - this is a
really good very entertaining Disney
movie well it doesn't have as much on
its mind it's a Zootopia that's not
really necessarily a flaw I mean it's a
lot of fun and kids are gonna love it
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'm gonna have more reviews
coming to you very soon from the films I
saw at AFI Fest you guys are the best
thank you very much as always and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes